hello my name is george tetz and i'm
chief scientific officer of new york
city-based companies tgvtx and human
microbiology institute
we're revolutionizing treatment of
infectious disease patients by a new
test system that is based on a new
paradigm of antibiotic selection
we select antibiotics that are
treat the bacterial community at the
site of infection as a whole
and this approach enables selection of
antibiotics active even against
infections caused by drug resistant
bacteria just in two hours
the particular problem is the
failure of traditional antibiotic
selection tests is to identify effective
antibiotics scenes these methods ignore
their critical characteristics of real
life infections and let me start maybe
with some numbers
antibiotic resistance is one of their
biggest health care challenges of our
time
and each year in the united states are
over at least
3 million people get an antibiotic
resistant infections
30 000 people die
and currently at least 700 000 die
there globally each year due to drug
resistant bacterial infections
and
although the most obvious idea is to
blame antibiotic misuse and lack of the
interest of pharma for the development
of a new antimicrobials i'm gonna do to
make another statement
the majority of deaths due to the
inefficacy of antimicrobials
are actually rarely attributed to
antimicrobial resistance in cell
actually it's a failure of antimicrobial
susceptibility tests to select an effect
of antibiotics i will tell you what i
mean
as of today the cases of the totally pun
resistant and treatable bacteria are
still rare
the majority of infections characterized
as multi-drug resistant
still leaves a number of therapeutic
options
and that means that very often when
antibiotic treatment failed that means
that actually the antimicrobial
stability test failed to select an
appropriate antibiotic to these patients
and there please take a look at this
antibiotic sensitivity data for
ceremonious originosa from a child with
cystic fibrosis fibrosis sorea from
washington university
you can see that pseudomonas regenosaur
is sensitive it seems to be sensitive
you know for at least three antibiotics
but in clinical practice for these
patients all these antibiotics fail why
because antibiotic
testing tests fail to select effective
antibiotics
and their existing methods for
antibiotic selection are based on
outdated and inaccurate microbiological
principles
therefore they have a significant
shortcomings which frequently
hinder the optimal patient treatment
it happens due to the study settings in
which the
antibioticability pattern is determined
only with elite pathogen grown as a pure
monobacterial culture but in real life
infection
the vast majority of human infections
are poly microbial
therefore as the site of infection the
lead pathogen normally is in a totally
different ecological environment
in this environment it is uh surrounded
and modulated by other bacteria which
modulate its proliferation and the
expression of antibiotic resistance
patterns
moreover bacteria share antibiotic
resistance with each other protecting
the whole community
uh oh like this paper it clearly
describes how different bacteria at the
site of infection form mixed biofilms in
which they support each other and that
happens with multiple mechanisms for
example by collective antibiotic
resistance
when certain antibiotic resistant
patterns secreted by one bacteria
protect the whole community
moreover recently published papers have
shown that sometimes the joint response
to antibiotics of the mixed community is
actually opposite to that of individual
bacteria
now uh let's return to adb finder which
is a really game-changing method to
select antibiotics
atv finder is a first-in-class
phenotypic-based test system enabling
the selection of effective antibiotics
just within four hours
antibiotics efficacy is the permit
against the whole mixed bacterial
community from the site of infection and
allows to overcome the issue of combined
antibiotic resistance
it can test the efficacy of a very large
number of antimicrobial agents at the
same time for the same biosample and
provides a list of antibiotics that are
effective for these patients
btw finder consists of a multi-well
prefabricated plate containing
aeronautical host mimicking not nutrient
media which we named tgb
and these media it resembles the
real-life polymerable infection
it enables simultaneous mixed bacterial
growth in the form of biofilm of nearly
all pathogens directly from the clinical
specimen
and it provides the colony appearance as
soon as within four hours
the tgd medium is well supplemented with
antibiotics
one or several antibiotics for each well
and also has several control wells with
antibiotic free media
the antibiotics are selected for the
existing therapeutic guidelines
and they're added to the medium of each
well at concentrations clinically
achievable at the site of infection
important we do not rely on using an
artificial minimal arbitrary
concentration numbers
but use the antibiotics concentrations
that can be achieved at this saturn
faction
the clinical specimens are plated
directly to the medium thus we're able
to eliminate the most time-consuming
step the isolation of pure bacterial
culture therefore saving over 40 hours
at least compared with conventional
culture-based methods for antibiotic
selection
there it is an example of our workflow
the human biosample
is added to the wells uh containing tgd
media with different antibiotics added
to each vl
and is incubated over a period of four
hours
uh just to highlight right there's no
need for the isolation of pure bacterial
culture
during this time during these flowers
due to unique properties of tgv or media
visible bacterial wheels appears
and
after that the analysis of the presence
or absence of microbial growth in each
world is done by determining
of the appearance offered thin film or
micro colonies on the surface of the
nutrient medium in each well just within
four hours
and comparing this result with the
initial pre-incubation for our zero hour
time period
within the same well and also with the
cultural wealth so just to reiterate the
labeling criteria for signing
antibiotics uh effective and ineffective
is based on their science of microbial
growth within each well and
growth control
the presence or absence of bacterial
growth is determined by the naked eye or
simple or measured vision camera device
and there just to summarize adb finder
selects antibiotic
antibiotics effective against the whole
microbial community
based on antibiotics concentrations that
can be achieved at the site of infection
and here's some real-life images
sorry the laptop is a little bit get
stuck in this place
in the course of a sunday uh the next
thing i would like to discuss is
the list of antibiotics that are
sort of the list of indications
that were picked up as our primary
locations and we're starting
with their use of adidas finder for the
treatment of different uh respiratory
tract infections starting from cystic
fibrosis patients uh
for undergoing land transplantation
patients with different types of ammonia
and copd
and also or you know by just adjusting
the panel of antibiotics we're able to
select antibiotics for patients with
utis or with skin and soft tissue
infections
this is our latest publication for ada
finder and just really briefly all right
here we compared the diversity of
bacteria that gave growth from the
different biosamples after tgb
er
you know comparing this data with those
that gave growth on uh standard lb or
guar medium and comparing with these
results
with the results of genotypic or 16 as
sequencing that was accepted as 100 of
all bacterial diversity so it's clearly
seen that tgv allows the growth of
nearly all microorganisms from the site
of infection according to the
you know meta-dynamic analysis
in our recent study our the visible
bacterial growth was detected in 119 out
of 122 monobacterial cultures and
all that happened already after four
hours and in 122 out of 122 cultures
after eight hours of cultivation of tgb
based on our knowledge no other meteor
are capable of similar performance
the overall sensitivity specificity
positive predictive and negative
predictive values uh varied from
98 to 99.6
that is a perfect result
well next to confirm that the clinical
response to antibiotics selected with
atp finder is higher than antibiotics
selected with conventional methods we
have conducted a prospective
longitudinal study on 35 patients with
cystic fibrosis
we compare the efficacy of antibiotics
selected with the use of standard ast
methods and antibiotics selected with
hdb5 and they're within the same
patients
uh so subjects served as their own
controls based on their clinical
performance when they were treated with
the antibiotic regimen which was
determined using conventional ast method
versus
those when they were selected with
edible finder
we first found that there was a
significant reduction in the number of
hospitalizations for pulmonary
exacerbation per year
once antibiotics
started to be selected with adb finder
compared to the time when antibiotics
were selected with the routine methods
there was a reduction of the total
number of annual hospitalizations giga
pulmonary extervation in the study group
from 45 in the baseline year comparing
to only two hospitalizations on the
first year of antibiotic selection with
adp finder and zero on this
their second year of antibiotic
selection with eighty to find it
on the right hand side you can see the
individual parameters um presented as
their
heat map so antibiotics selected the
data finder completely arrested
pulmonary existence
we also evaluated how
antibiotics selected with atp finder
affect systemic chronic inflammation
so we measured inflammatory markers
dynamic taken during a regular checkout
visits where the patients had no
problemative exacerbations
and there was a positive dynamic with
the reduction of both white blood cells
and therapy that correlate with lung
injury starting from the first year of
antibiotic selection with data finder
when it's observed changes of our
pulmonary pseudomonas or genor
and by year two of study after the
switch for the use of antibiotics
selected with adb finder eradication or
presumed eradication of pseudomonas
regenosa was noted in 26 out of 33
subjects who initially had pseudomonas
regionals
and the creep of the crown is the after
the dynamics uh sort of fev1 meaning
it's forced expiratory volume that is a
critical parameter of a lung function
in patients with cystic fibrosis so this
parameter is um
constantly decreased and depleted due to
pulmonary infections in patients with cf
and its improvement as a critical marker
for the reduction of a pulmonary
infection
through patients before the use of
antibiotics selected with data refined
there the mean after the one predicted
value was
44.2 percent and the use of antibiotics
selected with adb finder there was a
significant average absolute increase of
ftv one
by up to 65
by the second year
but when we analyze patients who at the
baseline period had after the one
predicted categorized as
very severely abnormal or severely
abnormal by year two antibiotic
selective they
that the absolute intercept increase was
over 28 percent
it's an absolutely unbelievable and
incredible result
just because there was suggested to have
you know to be in no way
why this parameter would be so
dramatically improved
but the gold standard of antibiotic
therapy for cf patients is to keep these
parameters
non-declining but we were able to
significantly increase
and finally they're switching to the
antibiotic uh select to the antibiotics
selected within refinery also increase
the body mass index of these patients
that also reflects the chronic
inflammatory parameters of the overall
inflammation processes of the body
this diagram which lies the total number
of systemic antibiotic courses
that were used within these by these 35
patients during the two-year timeline
period
based on selection of antibiotics with
the standard tasty methods and with adb
finder
each column represents the total number
of antibiotics
courses
during this
four year timeline period
and uh the
antibiotics used based on their
conventional ast methods they are
highlighted as is a red bar and uh
during the antibiotic courses selected
with adb finder as a gray bar one can
see that after antibiotics were selected
with adp finder the number of systemic
antibiotic forces was reduced from 355
to 178
or in other words we have retained at 55
reduction
uh to summarize the adb 500 addresses
exciting issues
um of current anti-microbial
susceptibility testing it goes beyond
the regular ast resistant profile of
bacterial infection uh
harshing the power of our proprietary
algorithm of populational response to
antibiotics within mixed biofilms
and it enables accurate selection of the
most effective antibiotics that are
active even against multidrug-resistant
bacteria and for the first time
selecting antibiotics that target both
the superbugs and their supporting
bacteria or bacteria helpers
and next we will launch a number of
other
clinical trials to formulate an
individualized antibiotic regimen
with atp finder in children with cystic
fibrosis and those undergoing land
transplantation so here's our
plan for the start date for this year we
are really very very close to launch
these three additional clinical sites
so thank you very much for
your attention we're currently looking
for new team members for our beautiful
new york city-based lab located in jail
labs
and now we're satellite lab in buffalo
so you're more than welcome to send your
resume to my personal email address
listed above
and there thank you very much for your
attention bye
you